hey guys back at Roseanne's kitchen
table you're still John Hoffman right
still slogan Hoffman dave rubin all
right so you might heard about this
SkyMall you know SkyMall the big thick
magazine that is in the back of the
airplane seats with all that fancy stuff
that you don't need and it's really
expensive but you kind of want they
filed for bankruptcy it's very sad don't
you feel so I feel so I actually sort of
feel sad I feel sad that it's gonna go
away but I don't feel bad for them
because they had a magazine with a
captive audience and they're saying
they're filing for bankruptcy because
everyone could get online right now
think of it this way if before your only
option was to look at skymall and you
couldn't get on the internet and screw
around now you can get on SkyMall and
actually buy stuff in the air before you
would have to circle stuff in skymall
and make a decision to buy it purchase
it when you got off the airplane is the
biggest no-brainer ever is to connect
the fact that you now have in seat
flight purchase power you can take your
credit out and use your phone to buy
something so so you're no sympathy for
them because they don't make the next
move into digital marketing and buying
hey didn't hire a consultant that had
the wherewithal to tell them to do in
air flash sale like a Groupon type thing
or living social work on this flight
only get you know the world's biggest
inflatable whatever the hell online for
free then it's their own do you fail
this is like opportunity opportunity
opportunity like mum's gonna give up if
you're not gonna you know take your sky
mall with you after the plane to circle
an item and purchase it with your
Telegraph I mean well your technology
and economic reasons notwithstanding I
actually really like this guy mall
because i love it because i'm not a good
flyer so i always need distraction so
now of course yeah you got Wi-Fi now
whatever but i would always want some
kind of distraction oh my god there's
eight pages of lord of the rings rings
by eight pages of Lord of the Rings
instantly from your seat and you figure
out how to make it happen at my god how
is that pops in marketing it's like
that's why I'm so he a more heated about
this then like Middle Eastern politics
I'm like how do you not get it together
yeah well this is probably also more
solvable the Middle Eastern products so
we wanted to just roll through a couple
of the things because there's so many
bonkers things on there that everyone is
buying so we're gonna throw it throw up
a couple images so the first one here is
a personal massager those right that it
looks very dildo II I like I got in
closer to you get it clean in there all
women yea tall women yes all women my
god personal
Roger yeah you can get the regular
7-inch massager for 2499 or the deluxe
nine and a half inches which would you
go for it well you know I like
everything deluxe one of these are not
even really trying to hide the fact that
this looks kind of just like a dick but
she's handling right here just rubbing
it yeah it's just a dick on her shoulder
casually it's not they don't even have
it like in any sort of former it doesn't
look like an actual penis which I love
that is just out there they should have
called it dick on her shoulder Scottie I
dig on your shoulder yeah that would
work the next one you know I've seen
people with these things so this giant
pillow that you put on the tray right in
front of you guys can sleep I it it
looks horribly uncomfortable and
ridiculous but people love it here's the
other thing this is a wedge pillow
people realize that a wedge pillow is
one of the highest biggie biggest sexual
items 24 yeah it's a wedge pillow that
this guy is sleeping on rice photo and
if you go to any online site and you
look at top products that are sexual
marital AIDS right our sexual aids um
yeah the wedge pillow is a huge thing
too so basically there's no why is the
wedge pillow cuz you can put it
underneath it helps with orgasms and you
could bend somebody over it if you want
to experiment with new different things
in bed it's sort of a kind of gives you
a guideline of where to put your body oh
this doesn't mean the wedge pillow is
gonna be discontinued then but no I
don't think there's any chance of that
the wage pillows actually there's two
clearly sexual items in a row and
they're both guys as like help you sleep
on a bed your back problems right
speaking of sexual things if you want to
get laid obviously you have to have ten
feet and that's why the solafeet foot
tanner like this to me is like the
epitome of what that magazine was all
about yeah some device solving
ridiculous problem another very nice yet
big problem well you get it people in
lot of cities wear flip-flops especially
los angeles everyone's always either
wearing shoes you can't wear flip-flops
to work so I get a weird tan I guess
this is just to make sure that if you
have a football town or something weird
that you won't have to suffer any I
wonder if you could put your hands in
there cuz you ever noticed how
especially people on TV because they're
so fake tan oh yeah their faces are
always nice and tan and their hands as I
bone white yeah well you could put your
hands in the foot tanner I think you can
do whatever you want I think even dare
to dream to turn your SkyMall technology
into whatever adventure you would like
prolly boys the warranty though this is
good a wrist watch can you say Irish
wristwatch I wrist wrist watch Irish I
alright when we're done I risk iris I
said it right the first time all of my
Scotch Irish wristwatch I was pretty
good all right you got it this is a
wristwatch that counts down your life I
mean that's terrible that sounds really
quite horrible okay your dad on make
every second count with the ticker
happiness watch inspiring you to live
your life to the fullest using
statistics and personal health algorithm
your average life expectancy is
calculated and then you can look at it I
mean that sounds really really terrible
bit and then finally you can sleep like
a baby while sitting up basically you
have to look like you're you were just
in some sort of horrible horrible
accident and but you could go to sleep
you could also go around filing lawsuits
against whoever put you in that terrible
condition all day that's what ever I see
a neck brace like that I just think of
80s movie and someone having a lawsuit
pending lawsuit for sure yeah anyway are
you guys gonna miss the the SkyMall
should they have listened to jen and
done a little digital they had years to
prepare for the internet and they did
nothing right cuz who's gonna fill out
the form you're like yeah clue they did
well when their job was harder but now
that their jobs easy they couldn't just
make more money their sales should have
gone up not down it's what I'm saying
what do you think did you ever buy
anything do you have the the neck dildo
or the like what's the weirdest thing
you've ever bought from Sky Mall lettuce
I like to know and subscribe and all
that good stuff